yeah hello and welcome to this short
video which is about something nice a
good news that I received just recently
that my keep it simple one in four book
the paper book Brady's the print book
release won an award yam the chess
publishing book of the year 2018 nice
and that means we need to celebrate and
how do we do that let's go if you go
into chasuble there are all my books we
have the keep it simple one year for the
fighting for a Khurana repertoire and my
English and Ben garbage was they are all
reduced so you get a discount now for
some days I think about ten days not
quite sure and you see they're heavily
discounted in particular the video parts
i heavily discounted so if you want to
get those books
the one that got the award keep it
simple one you form up for 12 days i
wasn't sure so they're all reduced and
also the other courses also the fight
before a karana gets a huge discount
which is actually a really good book
that did not go sell that well i think
it was probably um that was very
professional it's a repertoire not maybe
so immediately thrilling that same if
you look at it but it is a it is a very
good product anyway I hope you maybe can
use these discounts they're on for a
couple of days you don't have to react
immediately but if you intended to get
some of those products now is a good
time to do so by the way and looking at
this page I don't want to skip that
because there is also a book on now
which is excellent the chess structures
book by Mauricio I think Mauricio iflows
Rios that's a book that I haven't used
MHS training it's a very good book form
I would say I'm not
so how it is here on chasuble for
beginning players it's it's quite
sophisticated for beginning players I
think but if you want to learn about
pawn structures this is really an
excellent book so I'm just a quick info
I'm really happy about the way my book
has some received by I'm by the public
interview still interested in buying it
and haven't gotten it yet or any of the
other products there or what heavily
discounted things not for watching this
video bye bye